[Music]
the virus is a mystery that's making
lives a misery even before we'd ever
heard of Koba 19 there were people
living on the edge in this country more
than 3 million Canadians live below the
poverty line and about 4 million have
inadequate access to food now they're
slipping further Allyson bouche NIC
reports on the vulnerable who live on
the margins of society and need help now
more than ever
[Music]
here the pandemic cuts through exposing
the cracks the inequities that have long
existed
the borough of Montreal North is one of
the most devastated areas in the country
the Cova 19 infection rate is close to
double the average we can see that
ghovat 19 is hitting communities that
are socially and economically
marginalized or disadvantaged hardest
among those who already live in
difficult situations with lower incomes
many are also frontline health and
essential workers all that contributed
to the spread they're working in
occupations that already paid very
little but now have been deemed
essential right and because of that
because they already didn't have savings
and they have families to support they
have to go to work to put food on the
table living in multi-generational
racially and ethnically diverse and
high-density settings people start to
realize that the disproportionate impact
that kovat 19 has on certain population
groups while Canadians were told to stay
inside many of the most disadvantaged
had little choice I think about people
that don't have access to a car for
example so they have to take public
transit so they might just have to be in
settings where they are with mixing with
other populations at a greater frequency
and that's going to increase risk of
infection
[Music]
these critical issues are called the
social determinants of health social and
economic factors like income
discrimination access to quality food
health care and education all of it
impacts a person's health and how long
they will live also these are groups
that generally have already suffered
long-standing health inequalities so
they're more likely to be sick already
so it's really a variety of factors that
lead to them being much more vulnerable
to both getting code vid 19 and
suffering really terrible consequences
for those who study Public Health say
this was predictable the inequities
existed before the pandemic hit and a
communities across the country once the
infection became more community spread
we saw these gradients across
socio-economic size that have widened
over the course of the pandemic it's not
just about who gets infected the
pandemic is also impacting those in less
secure and low-paying jobs statistics
Canada says they have suffered greater
job losses
in the shadows they are suffering the
most vulnerable struggling before the
pandemic now even worse
it's almost impossible to have good
health without stable housing the
shelter system already under-resourced
scrambling to cope with physical
distancing and caring for this at-risk
group the virus claiming lives it's just
such a difficult situation any
congregate living situation this virus
has proven to be extremely contagious
and spread very easily and there are
others struggling many of those with
disabilities are suffering with programs
canceled and services reduced and so
many seniors are isolated at home to
understand how great the need is you
need to go to the agencies and charities
that are supporting the vulnerable it's
been tough for them as well donations
dropping physical distancing and the
need rising and the numbers like the
numbers have increased exponentially the
people that were in the lineups before
kovat aren't still there and now there's
twice as many
Second Harvest is Canada's largest food
rescue it is in the intersection of two
problems a food system with too much
wasted food and too many people going
hungry one kovat nineteen hit it really
magnified the existing problem and then
it created an even larger scale
challenge both with the amount of food
that is going into landfill and the
amount of people that really need to
access this food that's where food
rescue za comes in if someone has food
to donate anywhere in the country they
are connected with the charity in their
local community who needs it over sixty
thousand organizations in Canada sixty
thousand use food in their program
charities and nonprofits so we need to
map those charities with the 58 percent
of surplus and lost food to make sure
that it goes through the system and so
we do that with a matchmaking system
that I refer to as the eHarmony of food
because it's really simple
since the pandemic started the website
ramped up in March and it has helped to
rescue close to seven million pounds of
food and help thousands of charities
when the Second Harvest trucks roll out
the head to charities like the East
Scarborough Boys and Girls Club these
halls usually loud and lively now quiet
the programs and center is a lifeline
for so many from children to seniors
with its multiple programs it helps
close to 6,000 children and youth every
year it's unprecedented
now the help is coming in a new form the
club is receiving additional food from
Second Harvest than packaging hampers
it's been a huge challenge but an
opportunity I think across the sector
and for us locally to look at how we can
scale up our services to make sure we
are not letting anyone fall between the
gaps twice a week staff members are
personally taking the food to families
who need it so far delivering more than
5,000 hampers
dami Lola is trying to keep her
seven-year-old busy and safe as a single
mother she's still working from home but
her hours have been cut back paying for
rent and food and all the bills is no
longer possible things that's a worry
about okay your finances what's going to
happen your credit card what are we
going to do about that and then your
rent
thank ya so for the first time she's
receiving food hampers twice a week did
to help every week so that's a that's a
very good initiative and we're grateful
[Music]
she's grateful and this works for now
but if her rent returns to a full amount
and her income is still reduced she
could get into trouble fast if I was
paying my full rent and groceries
there's no way I can make look was there
more bills to pay and then the income is
not enough at this time back at the Boys
and Girls Club they know people are
anxious and need more help they are now
offering education supports and virtual
activities we've started to do analysis
across the community through our
assessments and the reality is that
looking at the metrics that may take
almost a year of these continued
emergency-type supports to support
families so that they can balance out
and resume some type of normalcy and
that raises a critical part of the
social and economic factors of health
data to see who is being impacted and
how best to help but the collection of
this information in Canada has been
inconsistent at best when we are missing
data on segments of the population that
are at risk it really hinders our
ability to make sure that our responses
are protecting those people or in worst
case scenario not making the situation
more risky for certain groups in the
population it also means we need to be
better prepared for targeting help
before the second wave of infection
starts the one thing about infectious
diseases is that that we neglect groups
of the population that means that the
outbreak will continue either any point
in time to understand that
anyone being affected means everyone
could be affected that challenge could
also present an opportunity in place of
staying reopening we say reimagining and
I think one of the ways we need to
reimagine our society is in a way that
will reduce the deleterious impact of
these social determinants of health
almost every single health problem you
can think of really breaks down along
socio-economic gradients and the most
vulnerable people always bear the worst
brunt to these health problems this
might be a sort of small window and we
can reimagine society to break that
cycle there's lots of help needed lots
of things to fix with me is dr. Andrew
Bruce Ari he's executive director of
Health and Social Policy at Toronto's
University Health Network doctor at the
start of this pandemic the virus was
referred to as the great equalizer
that's not really true is it no no Donna
the more and more we're learning the
more and more we're seeing there is
nothing equalizing about kovat it is
really a cruel exposure of long-standing
inequality and poverty you know we're
seeing this concentrate with the data
we're hearing this with the stories but
really none of this is surprising but
that's also what's compounding the
crisis and what's making it even more
worrisome for people who aren't on the
frontlines like you are can you explain
how the lack of safe housing and poverty
intersect to put people at greater risk
of getting kovat 19 kovat has you know
torn back the curtain on any sort of way
to ignore this of any sort of weight not
to see the connection if an individual
is experiencing homelessness they do not
have places to physically isolate they
are constantly at risk they are
constantly in situations where they're
not able to also have any usual or what
we would hope for healthcare delivery or
in healthcare access and then I think
the other challenge on this has also
been it's for the under house right as
well that we're seeing these issues of
where physical distancing is a privilege
it has not been afforded to all and what
we're seeing it come up with kovat is
that it's really coming
the cost and the expense of the poor
there needs to be an opportunity for
individuals to have the human dignity
and the protection that we would expect
and demand for everybody living in
Canada has not played out so I think you
know from you know again there is
incredible heroism by the individuals
who are experiencing this every hour of
the day who have had to look out for
family members for themselves there is
incredible courage by the frontline
shelter staff by community workers who
are in shelters who are in the
facilities to do all that they can to
help individuals from our health care
workers and hospitals but really what
we're seeing is that this is not a fault
of any individual these are not faults
of any collection of individuals but
these are structural issues insist
system level elements that have now been
exposed that have been I would argue
exposed for a long time but are now
really unemotional eyes people in
society more at risk as that happens are
they more at risk as we start to open up
or have some supports been put in place
for them or there are their safe places
for example for them to quarantine or
recover if they've been sick you know I
think that the reopening comes with
really serious risks for those who are
already most disadvantaged and we've
seen this from from data where it's
individuals again or at the frontline to
individuals who we've called you know
essential workers now but for a long
time we also had no issue calling
unskilled or minimum wage but they have
had maximal courage in doing what they
need to do to allow whatever parts of
the economy have stayed open whatever
parts of services have stayed open have
really been through the courage and
dedication of these workers who have
deemed essential and I hope that we also
continue in that same respect in that
same view of the things that they need
to happen and really I just think it's
about individuals being able to have the
confidence and trust in the system as
things reopen the economy will never
come back to life if there's no
confidence and I think that the other
piece of this is we will never see the
health outcomes we want if there's not
trust in the system that people are not
going to be overlooked that people are
not going to
neglected and people are not going to be
you know essentially sacrificed for
certain parts of the economy to restart
while individuals again have been under
chronic neglect and now it's not hard to
connect the dots as to the risks that
they're under do you think they were
opening up the economy too quickly those
who are most at risk of this with the
opening of their economy are racialized
marginalized populations we've seen this
with personal support workers again
where this has long been known that it's
usually racialized women in these
situations who have been under a
precarious employment not having the
control and autonomy that we would hope
for everyone working in our health care
system they've had to have you know this
courage and this dedication for years
and again kovat has blown the top off
any of these issues of where people have
been in precarious work where people
have been in unsafe work conditions and
so again when the economy reopens
it's those individuals who will be at
the forefront it's those individuals who
will face the consequences and I think
again we have to go back to decide what
do we owe each other what elements at
what levels of protection need to be in
place before we can safely real
[Music]